susur la glace pour ce match
dede pee-wee AAA qui oppose
l'l'Intrépide de Gatineau
auaux Grenadiers de Châteteaugu.
ChCharles Romain et ses deux jus
dede ligne veillent au grain.
CeCelui qui arbitre depuis
cicinq ans le fait par passion,
bibien plus que pour le salaire.
CHCHARLES ROMAIN, arbitre
- - Souvent. on fait 25 piasses
dede la game environ, mais on et
icici pour genre 2 h 30, puis on
ararrive une demi-heure avant,
unune demi-heure après.s.
CÇa paye un peu moins que...
quque de travailler au Subway
ouou quelque chose.
- - La faible rémunération est n
fafacteur qui explique la pénure
d'd'arbitre au Québec.
DeDe plus, leur salaire est
mamaintenant imposé, ce qui
didiminue l'attrait d'enfiler
lele chandail noir et blanc,
paparticulièrerement pour les
ararbitres les plus expérimenté.
L Le comportement agressif
dedes spectateurs envers
leles officiels est aussi montré
dudu doigt.
RIRICHARD TROTTIER, directeur de
l'l'arbitrage LHJMQ
- - C'est sûr r que pour un jeu,
alaller se faire engueuler
sisi on veut à l l'aréna,
pepeut-êtrtre qu'il va préférer
alaller se trouver un autre
ememployeur. Puis je pense
ququ'il y a bien des endroits
ququi en recherchent présentemet
dedes travailleurs.
- - En Outaouais, le quart des
ararbitres ont quitté cette ann.
8585 % d'entre eux avaient plus
dede cinq saisons d'expérience.
UnUne expérience qui sera
didifficile à r remplacer.
MAMARK LOYER, arbitre en chef
rérégional de l'Outaouais
- - À des niveaux M15 et M18,
onon fait des systèmeme à t tros
ofofficiels. Donc, un arbitre de
chcharge et deux juges de ligne.
AÀ ce niveau-là, , au lieu
d'd'annuler une partie,
ququ'est-ce qu'on va faire,
onon va déplacer les arbitres,
onon va faire ça avec deux juges
dede ligne et non une personne
enen charge.
P Patine, puis pointe vers la
blbleue...
- - Malgré tout, la région
s's'attend à a attirer 50 nouvex
ararbitres. Des passionnés,
cocomme Saloum Arrès-s-Ostiguy,
ququi a enfilé le chandail zébré
ilil y a quatre ans.
SASALOUM ARRÈS-OSTIGUY, arbitre
- - Y'a beaucoup de jeunes
ququi me regardent comme :
"L"Lui, il a réussi à  êtrtre
ararbitre, peut-êtrtre que moi
jeje vais êtrtre arbitre".
EtEt ça aide aussi avec le stres
etet tout ça. T'es en charge,
c'c'est toi qui décides,
c'c'est toi qui fais ce que tu
veveux. Et tu essais de te donnr
auau maximum pour les jeunes.
- - La solution à c court terme:
coconvaincre les vétérans de
chchausser à n nouveau les pati.
MaMais les ligues devront
auaussi redoubler d'effort
popour attirer la relèveve
etet éviter qu'elle ne quitte.
I Ici Rémi Authier,